this morning we are giving you an inside
look at unprecedented
series of tests that prove airline
cleaning techniques
do effectively kill the coronavirus the
research was funded by boeing
university of arizona and boeing
researchers used a live but harmless
virus to test the cleaning process
on real planes chris van cleave has more
on the study and what it means about the
safety of flying in a pandemic
university of arizona researchers
working with boeing are applying a live
virus that's harmless to humans but more
resilient than covet 19
to airplane surfaces flyers are most
likely to touch
they then applied the enhanced cleaning
techniques airlines have been rolling
out since the pandemic began
disinfectants electrostatic sprayers
anti-microbial coatings
and this ultraviolet light wand boeing
developed to clean
cockpits the researchers found all four
procedures were shown to effectively
kill covid
all of these processes and technologies
together can give us a virus free
airplane this follows research from the
department of defense and darpa using a
test dummy that simulates a coughing
passenger
during each test the dummy spewed out
180 million particles
that's the equivalent to thousands of
coughs
when the dummy wore a mask testing found
on average just .003 percent of the
particles reached another passenger's
breathing zone
specifically can i tell you sit and see
xyz
no they all perform very well this week
seven months into the pandemic the cdc
strongly recommended people wear a mask
when flying
are in a transit hub on mass transit or
in a ride share
airbus says its research found if
passengers wear masks
the number of droplets reaching another
passenger is lower than what it would be
on the ground with social distancing
because of the plane's air circulation
and hospital grade filtration systems
infectious disease expert dr carlos del
rio it's just not one thing it's sort of
adding all those different things really
makes you know playing
flame travel very very safe airlines say
there have only been about 44
documented cases of a passenger getting
coveted during a flight
and all but two of those happened before
mass mandates were in place
now critics say it's hard to get a firm
number because so many people can be
asymptomatic
and contact tracing in the u.s is
lacking
for cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave
washington